une situation pas évidente à temps
mélanie therrien sa famille à l'automne
ses deux enfants deux ados n'auront pas
accès à l'or transports scolaires je
sais pas comment on va pouvoir
s'organiser pour transporter deux
premiers élèves dans deux écoles
différentes de deux municipalités
différentes résidences d'une
municipalité éloigné de la rive sud de
québec le transport en commun ne s'y
rend tout simplement pas pour respecter
les règles actuelles de la santé
publique
les commissions scolaires doivent
diminuer le nombre d'élèves à bord des
autobus à moins d'un changement leurs
capacités plongera donc de 72 à
seulement 23 passagers sur la rive sud
de québec
à la commission scolaire des navigateurs
ça veut dire une diminution de 70% du
nombre d'élèves et c'est selon ces
critères que les parents doivent dès
maintenant
paniquée la rentrée il ya des choix
déchirants on doit faire des choix
difficiles
donc on a annoncé dans le fond on
parlera le retrait de certains services
qu'on offrait de façon régulière afin de
réussir à rentrer dans notre 30 % de
capacité de transport par exemple les
parents qui ont fait le choix d'envoyer
leurs enfants dans un établissement
autre que leur école de quartier
n'auront plus de transports scolaires
c'est le cas du fils de mélanie terrier
elle croit que la santé publique devrait
alléger ces critères les élèves enjoy
copé beaucoup au niveau des
apprentissages y ont fait leur part
setha pour tout recommencer recommencer
les cours le plus normalement possible
c'est aussi ce que pense le syndicat qui
représente des employés du transport
scolaire de la région de québec au
niveau des enfants la problématique de
complications ou même d'attraper le coc
vide et minimes
dans ces conditions l'homme moi je
considère la seule problématique que
dans un autobus scolaire
c'est le chauffeur versus les élèves
selon elle la solution est simple le
gouvernement devrait subventionner les
barrières en polycarbonate pour protéger
les chauffeurs comme c'est le cas dans
le transport en commun
son neveu le port du masque pour les
jeunes nous autres avec notre barrière
en politique en polycarbonate de
transport scolaire pourrait reprendre
d'une façon totalement normal le
ministre de l'éducation jean françois
roberge tente d'obtenir des
assouplissements de la santé publique
pour l'instant cependant les consignes
actuelles demeurent ici marie pierre
merci radio canada québec